[Applaudissements]
j'ai trouvé tout ce que ce mandat nous
offrir
retirez vos entraves embrasser le large
mon trésor je vous le laisse si vous
voulez
alors tu en dis quoi
tu es avec moi
[Musique]
quel intérêt y a-t-il à devenir pirate
c'est la plus belle chose au monde
les embruns
le vent qui te souffle dans le dos
ton équipage loyal à tes côtés ça y est
je dois avoir quoi là notre pavillon
noir pour l'équipage du Chapeau de
Paille
on s'est lancée
zone dangereuse de l'océan vous les îles
sont plus grandes et les pirates plus
puissants et c'est là qu'on va trouver
le One Piece
on se fait à chaque fois fait des
ennemis quel que soit l'endroit
S
[Musique]
il faut leur pardonner ce sont des
gamins
[Musique]
rien ne peut l'arrêter
je vais faire preuve de bonté en vous
exécutant tous les deux ensemble
tu es mon capitaine dès maintenant et
jusqu'à la fin
je vais donc de beauté le cul parce que
personne m'embête mes amis
je vois vraiment pas ce que tout le
monde te trouve
[Musique]
je suis monkey
et je vais devenir le roi des pirates
je savais pas qu'il y avait autant de
pirates c'est horrible c'est clair
[Musique]
depuis que je suis enfant
j'entends l'appel de la merde
du coup je me prépare à réaliser mon
rêve
[Musique]
le roi des pirates ce sera moi
pour ça il me faut un équipage joyeux
toi et moi
je suis sûr qu'on formerait une super
équipe
on s'est lance sur la route de grande
line
zone dangereuse de l'océan où est-il
sont plus grandes et les pirates plus
puissants
fais un peu attention je suis pas sous
tes ordres il y a un peu de tension dans
mon équipage j'ai l'impression mais pas
[Musique]
notre équipage est encore tout frais
mais on se fait entièrement confiance
tous les grands guerriers
[Musique]